hey what's up this is editorial
assistant Andrew Goble today I'm
checking out one of the spookiest
haunted houses in all of New York City
it's actually my first haunted house in
all 23 years of my life and I'm not
feeling great about it one time I had to
be escorted down from the top of Tower
Terror because I was too scared and this
seems like 35 times worse so let's see
how it goes
right
oh oh my
God oh my God no thanks no thanks oh
holy no no
no oh God oh my God all right going to
move hello Hi how are you Hi no no no
hi holy
more friend so
nice holy
oh oh
hello come
on oh my God I'll come back I'll come
back I swear to God hello hello
hello woo
so oh my God I need like cut the shakes
here never
again 100% never
again